I hope inshallah that we will
benefit from the words and
advice of our brother Dr Zakir Nik
inshallah time is taking on and I would
like to
immediately go into the question and
answer
session I would like to lay out the
ground
rules for this part of the program
inshallah
questions not relevant to the topic
including any general question on
religion will not be
permitted kindly State your question
briefly and to the
point only one question at a time may be
asked for your second question you'll
have to go at the end of the queue and
await your second chance to ask a
question
non-muslim brothers and sisters will be
given First Press reference to ask
questions two mics have been provided in
the
auditorium I believe there is one here
to the left there's one here to the
right the format will be that the
sisters will use the mic to my left and
the brothers will use the mic to the
right we will allow one question at each
of the mics in clockwise rotation
written questions on slips of papers
available to with our volunteers on the
side sides and in the centralizes will
be given secondary preference after Dr
zakar Nik finishes answering the
questions asked on the mic and only if
time permits so kindly state your name
and your profession before putting forth
your question I would like to ask you
those Brothers to and sisters to ask who
wish to ask questions to form an orderly
queue and we will commence in just a few
moments
inshallah are there any non-muslims in
our audience who would like to ask
questions please come forward the mic is
free and we will give the non-muslims
reference inshallah good evening andam
alaikum to
everyone I'm councelor nain sha leader
of hero
Council I'd like to uh give a very warm
welcome to Zakir B on behalf of hero
Council and Multicultural multifaith
community of heror you're very very
[Applause]
welcome since I'm limited to one
question I will follow the discipline
it's been very thought provocating
address I'm very grateful for that you
have
analyzed to some degree of detail
various religions the Islam the Hinduism
Judaism and and even atheists is it a
question of equality of religions or do
you reckon that there is a case for
supremacy of one religion against
another thank you the brother asked a
very good question that is there a
question of supremacy of one religion
over the other
religion basically what is the meaning
of the word religion religion means a
way of
life I rather believe what the Quran
says rather than talking about Supremacy
the Quran say
says come to Common terms as been us and
you if there is a question of Supremacy
then each one will try and prove that
the religion is the best so rather the
Quran advises when we speak with people
following other
religion come to commment terms as been
and you so I personally disagree with
the interfa dialogues that take place
normally in the world normally what
happens that there is a person coming
from the Christian faith priest and
coming that all religions are the same
Christianity is the same Hinduism is the
same Islam is the same then you have a
Hindu pundit coming and saying Hinduism
is also correct and same Islam is the
same Christianity same then they get
Joker Muslim who comes and says that
Islam is the same Hinduism Christianity
is same see I being a student of Islam
and compared religion it's a big lie to
say that all religions are the same
there are commonalities but they aren't
the same there are differences I can
talk more about differences than the
similarities but the Quran encourages to
talk about
similarities what my strategy is brother
that I tell that at least let us agree
that one religious scripture is 100%
perfect so the Christian would say fine
I don't mind believing that Bible is
100% the word of God the Hindu would say
I would not mind believing the vas to be
the word of God the Muslim will say I
don't mind considering Quran to be the
word of God I'm not trying to put
anything on the top of somebody's head
not going to put anything down the
throat now what I say that what is
common in all these scriptures at least
let us agree to follow that
strictly what is different we'll discuss
it later on so when we come and try and
find the commonalities in all the
scriptures we find that the commonality
is the same all of the religious
scriptures say believe in one God I give
you references from the Bible Bible
Moses peace be upon him said in the book
of om number 6 verse number
four isra the Lord our God is one Lord
when Jesus Christ peace be upon us asked
that which is the first of the
Commandment he repeated a ver with him
the same thing in the gospel of Mark
chapter number 12 verse number
29 which
means the Lord our God is one Lord if
you read the Hindu scriptures if you
read the upanishads it's mentioned Chad
chapter number six section number 2
verse number
one it's a Sanskrit quotation which
means god is one without a second it's
mentioned in
the chapter number six verse number
n which means of that God he has got no
Superior he has no Lord he has got no
parents he has got no mother he has got
no father he has got no Superior it's
mentioned in chapter number four verse
number
19 of him there is no images
I can give quotations from bhagat Gita
upanishad Veda several talking about
Oneness of God so I say that why don't
all of us believe in one God bhagwad
Gita chapter number 7 verse number 20
says that all those with intelligence
has been stolen by material desires they
worship demig gods they do it worship so
if you read The Vedas and bhagwat Gita
and the upanishads they say there's one
God it's against idol worship they don't
believe in almighty God coming down they
believe in almighty God sending
Messengers so I say that let us the
Hindus the Jews the Christians the
Muslims at least believe that we worship
none but one almighty God and that God
has got no images he cannot be begotten
it's mentioned in the bible it's
mentioned bhagad G mentioned in the
Quran if you studied all these
scriptures the next point you come to
know which is common is that there's
going to come a final and last messenger
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him I
gave you quotations in my lecture about
Judaism in Christianity I can give you
references even from the Hindu
scriptures if Bish
kokas 10-27 it speaks about Muhammad
sahi wasallam it speak about K suas book
number 20 him number 127 verse number 1
to 14 speak about Muhammad sahi wasallam
there is a book called as Ki purana it
speaks about Anar AAR to come it's
mentioned in the Hindu scriptures in
kipana that there is a final AAR antim
last messenger going to come whose
mother's name shall be suti which means
peaceful which means Amina it says the
father's name shall be of one who
worships almighty God Vishnu Yash
translated to Arabic it means Abdullah
the name of the parents of muhamad
sallallah Al wasallam it says that he
will be born on the 12th month of mad
which is 12th RAB it says that he will
be the last and final Messenger mhammad
s last and final messenger it says that
he'll be held with four companions
talking about the first four calips of
Islam and on and on he'll be born in the
place which is known as peaceful sambala
which is Makkah he'll be born in the
family of the chief of Makkah I've given
the talk on Muhammad s Hindu scriptures
so second point of commonalties
according to me after bringing one God
you have to follow the last and final
Messenger to
come that is Prophet Muhammad sallu Al
wasallam it speaks about life after
death the Jewish scriptures Christian
scriptures Hindu scriptures and Islam
when Hindu scripture speaks about
Punam it speaks about next life it
doesn't speak about life death Life
Death that's a misconception punner
means next Jam means life we believe in
life after death but not being born and
death born dying born dying that's a
misconception so what I say at least let
us agree what is common so all the major
religious scriptures whether it be
Judaism Christianity Hinduism Islam
speak about one God and speak about a
final Messenger to come whose name shall
be Muhammad sallallah Ali wasallam so if
all of them follow the last and final
messenger they'll have to follow the
Revelation given to him have to follow
the Quran so rather than talking about
Supremacy we have to go back there's
only one
religion and the one religion as Allah
says in the Quran inah Al Imran chapter
number 3 verse number
19l the only religion acceptable in the
sight of almighty God is submitting your
will to almighty God
Islam submitting a will to almighty God
it's not a label a person by keeping his
name Muhammad Sultan Abdullah Zak he
will not go to heaven just by having a
Muslim name Muslim is a person who
acquires Peace by submitting his will to
almighty God so all the religious
scriptures that came previously brother
by the passage of time they have been
changed Quran is the last and final
Revelation which has been kept in its
pure form but in spite when all the the
scriptures have been changed according
to the scholars you read the books of
Hindu Scholars of Christian Scholars
they say the scriptures have been
changed but even after they have been
change there are remnants of Truth in
them which speak about the last and
final messenger Muhammad sallu Ali
wasallam and talking about one God so if
you go back to your scriptures and at
least follow the commonalities there
nothing like Supremacy will culminate
only to one religion that is submitting
a will to almighty God hope that answer
the
question
[Applause]
can I ask if there are any sisters who
are non-muslims who would like to ask a
question first on the sister's side is
any non-muslim sister wishes to ask a
question good evening Dr n my question
to you this evening is with all due
respect to Islam you said that idol
worship is the greatest sin in Islam and
Allah does not forgive an idol
worshipper for this but what about
people who have been born into fam of
religions other than Islam for example
in India most of the population is Hindu
and lifelong they may not have had
exposure to Islam or somebody else who
may have educated them about that what
is the fault of those people will they
never reach Paradise will Allah never
let these people enter Paradise what is
their fault if they believe what is
being taught to them since the day they
were born does Allah not have mercy on
them thank you s ask very good question
very logical question what about those
human beings who are born in non-muslim
families and the parents are doing idol
worship so who's to blame how can Allah
punish them and that's a very good
question that the reason a beloved
Prophet Muhammad sallallah Al wasallam
said that every child is born in every
child is born as a Muslim irrespective
whether is born in a Jewish family or a
Christian family or a Hindu family or a
Muslim family he is born as a Muslim
Muslim as I told earlier by definition
means a person who submits the will to
almighty God so every child when he's
born he submits his will to almighty God
later on he is influenced by his Elders
by his parents by his teachers then he
may start doing idol worship he may
start doing fire worship and he may go
to the wrong path that's the reason
whenever a non-muslim accepts Islam the
more appropriate word is revert it's not
convert convert means going from one
Faith to another Faith revert means a
person was on the right Faith went to a
wrong faith and came back to the right
Faith so the more appropriate word
sister is revert now now coming to a
question how can Allah hold responsible
a person if he's born in a non-muslim
family that's the reason if a child is
born in a non-muslim family before he
gains maturity if he dies he will go to
Jenna inshallah why every child submits
to almighty God he's a Muslim he may
have a Hindu name or a Christian name
John ramu it doesn't make a
difference but as long as he's a child
and if he dies as a child sister that
child will go to jna irrespective
whether he's born in a Muslim family or
non-muslim
family later on when a child grows up
and he becomes an adult then it is his
responsibility what he
does that's the reason if a child
commits a crime the court is lenient
when he becomes an adult then he cannot
say that my father taught me to Rob
therefore I'm
robbing if a child grows up at the age
of 22 and if the police catches him
after robbing he cannot say that my
father taught me to Rob therefore I'm
robbing will the judge let him go if
he's a child at the age of five the
judge may say fine he's a child he
hasn't attain maturity but once he
becomes an adult and then if that adult
tells the judge that I'm robbing because
my father T me to Rob he will not be
excused everyone responsible for his or
her own deed now once a person becomes
an adult it's the duty of that adult to
find the truth it's the duty of us
Muslims to convey the message to the
non-muslim
but irrespective whether a person gets
the message or not if a human being is
set free there were two tribes which did
not come in contact with modern
civilization till as late as 1950 one
tribee was the kapaku tribe and the
second was the astr and aborigin these
two tribe did not come in contact with
modern civilization till as late as 1950
and when researchers went and tried to
find out what was the way of
life it was nothing but Islam but they
didn't call themselves Muslims they
believe in one God they believe that God
had got no images he had no Idols they
prostrated when they worship God it was
everything of Islam but in
name so if a child is not given any
external influence he submits his will
to almighty God and remains on that path
now once a person becomes adult it's the
duty of us Muslims to convey The Message
of Islam if we do not convey Allah will
hold us
responsible he'll hold us responsible
but irrespective whether we do the job
or not we'll be responsible but Allah
says in the Quran in Sur f chapter
number 41 verse number
53 that soon we shall show them our
signs in the furtherest regions of the
horizons and into their soul until it is
clear to them that this is the truth
Allah has taken upon
himself that he will directly convin
this message to every human being
himself so if a Muslim does his job or
not whether we have good examples or bad
example Allah will directly put in the
heart of every human being whether
Muslim or non-muslim about the truth
about one God so once the message comes
that human being may follow may not
follow he may not follow thinking that
if I accept Islam I may have to give up
the things which I like I have to give
up my alcoholism I may have to give up
dating and dancing and and you know
whatever thing which is Haram in Islam
he may not accept the message then he's
responsible similarly if the father
teaches him something wrong to Rob it's
his duty to realize that robbing is
Haram it's a sin it's a thing which is
wrong he cannot go and tell the judge
that because my father taught therefore
I'm robbing similarly here when Allah
directly puts the message into the heart
of every human being about the H about
the Oneness of God and the idle worship
ship is prohibited yet if the individual
continues he or she is responsible so on
the day of judgment therefore Allah says
that no non-muslim will ever object to
the justice of
Allah because your organs will give
witness about you your eyes your hands
will speak about you so on the day of
judgment even those people who will be
put in hell they will never object to
the justice of Allah subh wa tala what
they will say please give us one more
chance and Allah will say it's too late
there are many chances given in this
world but to live only once in this
world so on the day of judgment no
non-muslim no human being even if he's
put in hell will ever object to the
justice of Allah he'll only say that
please forgive me and it will be too
late whatever is there in this world
this world as Allah says in Sur M
chapter 16 verse number two is a test
for the Hereafter hope that answer the
question
[Music]
sister is any other non-muslim who
wishes to ask a question to Dr Zakir n
if not then you may proceed sir thank
you asalamu alaykum my name is nid Ahmed
and I'm a surgeon to be a good surgeon
you need to be well trained I just
wanted to ask Dr Nike to do da well how
important do you think training is has a
question that he a surgeon and to be a
surgeon he had to be trained to dawa
don't you have to be well trained yes
brother but the question is a beloved
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam
said
inkari propagate even if you know one
verse so if you know one verse at least
go and convey that if you say that I
will wait till I become like Sheik Ahmed
and then start doing dawa the time will
never come so the thing the criteria for
doing surgery you have to get your
degree if you don't get your degree and
if you do surgery you may be arrested or
you may put behind bars fine similarly
for da even if you know one verse as
long as you know it correctly
you have to do dawa now as in medicine
you mbbs then there is MD then there is
DM MSS there then MCH is there fine the
more you keep on spending time the more
you'll become an expert now for doing a
surgery you may spend minimum about six
seven years correct only after passing
your 12th standard or a level whatever
it is
here how much time have you spend for da
how
much so when we want to become an
engineer you spend four years when you
want to be a after you spend 5 years
dawa you want to do overnight you can't
become an expert overnight but at least
you make a beginning at least open your
mouth as far as I'm
concerned in my childhood I was a
stammerer even in my adult I was a
stamer if you ask me what was my name my
name is Zak that was me when I met she
Ahmed inspired by him and I started
doing dawa and I realized when I spoke
with non-muslims I never used to stammer
normal a normal human being when he
comes on the stage he a stammer in my
dreams I could have dreamed of becoming
the best surge in the world I could have
dreamed you know in your dreams you can
dream anything but I couldn't dream of
speaking in front of 25 people I was a
stamer and now alhamdulillah with
Allah's
help I'm giving talks in fronts of
thousands of people hundreds of thousand
I've been given a talk in front of a
million people life
alhamdulillah so if you go back if you
see my life back I would be the last
person one of the last category who
could do dawa but I did Jihad Jihad
means to strive I didn't take a sword to
strive and struggle I did Jihad I
strived and I struggled and Allah opened
up the pathways Allah says in Surah anab
29 verse number 69 if you strive in
Allah's path Allah will open up your
ways I strived alhamdulillah and the
moment I got involved in the field of
dawa my staming went away yet I do time
or sometimes off the stage but on the
stage alhamdulillah Allah helps me it's
a miracle I was inspired by shed
whatever I learned whatever I heard from
his cassets I started talking I started
talking Allah kept on helping me more
and more and now I'm here even if I had
been the best sergeon in the world all
of you wouldn't have gathered here
correct and the respect that Allah has
given me at this young age even if i'
been the best sergeon in the world the
people that want to meet me the people I
meet the Kings the shakes the ministers
alhamdulillah I never did dawa for fame
or popularity I took up medicine I'm a
medical doctor because I thought it was
the most noble profession it is
alhamdulillah I'm not saying no but I
found a nobler profession therefore I
changed from a doctor of the body to
doctor of
soul but the best thing brother whatever
you have heard
today people normally enjoy they clap
tomorrow back to work they are the same
when they go back to work they should
try and repeat something from me what
they have heard at least 10% if not 10%
5% at least 2% start and the moment you
start Allah will help
you so the moment you keep on doing da
Allah help you I haven't done any course
I haven't been trained by
anyone Allah mallah help me and without
help it's not possible but we have dawa
training courses in Bombay where we
train people it's a short course of
about 30 to 40 days where we train
people and believe me if you hear the
speakers of a foundation all of them can
quote chapter number verse number Bible
bhagad Gita Hadith Quran alhamdulillah
at the
fingertips first is help of Allah second
is hard work third is technique so
number one is Allah's help hard work is
from you Technique we give that is the
least important but you don't wait till
you become an expert whatever you know
start and then Allah will help you more
hope the answer the
[Applause]
question I have a question here from a
non-muslim brother his name is Peter Dr
sa can you explain why is music Bad the
non-muslim friend as the question that
why is music bad there's no direct
reference in the Quran which speaks
about music as being bad there are
indirect references but there are
hadiths of prophet MMI wasallam who has
committed on music musical instruments
the only thing he permitted was the Duff
and the others he had not permitted the
reason being that most of the time when
musical instruments are used it normally
puts a person in a trance in a different
frame of mind and many times if you
analyze the Quran the Quran is against
songs and poetry there's a full chapter
sh that speaks about poets what happens
that normally in songs and
music the songs that are there if you
analyze the
words most of the songs they are away
from reality and and in a song when
people start praising or impressing the
opposite person the more they try to
impress the opposite person the more
they deviate from reality therefore in
Hindi film songs you'll find that the
hero tells the heroine
that I'll get for you the moon and get
for you the star which is not possible
and same thing when you in the English
pop and rock it has no meaning per many
of the songs some have got not at all
and it takes a person away and along
with the musical instruments whether it
be heavy metal you know we find that
people go in a frenzy they take out
their clothes and they different frame
of mind so most of the time the music
takes you away from Allah subhana wa
ta'ala so that the reason the prophet
has discouraged and said that musical
instrument should not be used except for
the duff that is there it takes a person
away from Allah subhana rather towards
Allah subhana
tala can I ask sister from this side
please thank you
I just wanted to ask about the meaning
of the
froml the Muslim umah is one umah at the
exclusion of all others their land is
one their war is one their peace is one
their trust is one and is this Hadith
relevant to us Muslims living in a
non-muslim society whose armies are
killing Muslims expelling them from
their homes and fighting them as we
speak the sister wants me to throw some
light on the Hadith of Prophet M
wasallam that the Muslim is one um
irrespective whether you're living and
there are various Hadith the prophet
said that it's like one body and if one
part of the body is hurt then all the
rest of the body is also in pain so in
that context as far as the Muslim umah
is concerned irrespective whether they
living in a Muslim Society or non-muslim
Society whether living in UK or America
or Saudi Arabia the Muslim umah is one
and if one part of the umah has hurt
it's the duty as far as possible
whatever ability a person has got he
should see to it that he helps so there
are various situations for example if
you know that there's one part of the
Muslim um which is poor or doesn't have
enough resources to feed themselves it's
the duty of the other part of the um to
see to it that they give them whether it
be from zakat money or from satka money
whatever it is so that they help the
other part of the Muslim umah now we
know the scenario is such that we find
that certain portion of the Muslim umah
they are being attacked they are being
harmed so whatever capacity we have and
whatever ability we have God it is a
duty that we as Muslims as our beloved
Prophet mamm sahi wasallam said that if
you find anything evil the best is to
stop it with your hand if you cannot
stop it with your hand then stop it with
the tongue if you cannot stop with the
tongue the least you can do is curse in
your heart and then if you do that you
are the lowest level of a Muslim so when
you see anything wrong if you can stop
it with the hand do it if you cannot
stop with your hand then try and stop it
with the tongue if you can't do that at
least curse in your heart if you find
something is happening maybe a robber is
taking place if Allah has given you the
ability go and stop with your hand if
you feel that the person they have got
most strength you are a lean person and
there 10 of them at least stand stop
with your tongue Please Mr don't Rob if
you can't do that at least curse in your
heart now depending on on the ability
that we have
got we have to do that now we find
unfortunately that the scenario that we
have that especially after
911 we know that what happened in 911
was wrong Allah clearly mentioned in Sur
MAA 5 verse number 32 that if anyone
kills any other human being whether
Muslim or non-muslim unless it be for
murder or for creating corruption in the
land it is as though he has killed the
whole of humanity so killing any
innocent human being is Haram
so what happened in 911 more than 3,000
or 5,000 people were killed innocent
people it is to be condemned who did it
I don't
know the media says XY Z I don't know
but whoever did it it is wrong what
happened in
London on the 7th of July where more
than 50 people were killed innocent
human being it is to be condemned
whoever did it is at fault it is wrong
but what we have to
realize that unfortunate
when Muslims live in non-muslim society
they try to be over
apologetic we find in America we find in
UK all the Muslim body got together and
they condemned the 911 correct no
problem they condemned what happened in
7th of July in London which I to condemn
but in the same breath we also have to
condemn the thousands of people killed
in Afghanistan we also have to
condemn
[Applause]
Allah we also have to condemn the
thousands of people killed in Iraq
what's happening in Palestine every day
Muslims are being killed what happened
in Bosnia we have to condemn that too
why do we stop unfortunately when I read
reports all the Muslim bodies get
together and they're condemning only
part of it why it's the same what is
wrong is wrong if a Muslim kills an
innocent human being he has to be
condemned similarly if a non-muslim
kills innocent Muslim even he has to be
condemned who are we afraid of but you
have to do it with hikma if you fear
that you opening your
mouth will create a
problem but don't mention wrong things
therefore as a DI we should know how to
turn the tables over with
hikma so what we have to realize that
what is wrong we have to condemn and
believe me I've been to America several
times in USA and Canada I've been to UK
the thing is that that if you realize
what a talk I give on Islam and
terrorism in all that was the topic what
we have to realize that many of times
two different labels are given for the
same activity of the same individual for
example in India there were many Indians
who were fighting for the freedom about
60 70 years back when the britishers
were ruling India now these people who
fought for the Freedom by the British
government they were called as terrorist
but we common Indians we call them as
Freedom Fighters same people same
activity but two different labels if if
you agree with the view of the British
government that they had a right to rle
over India you have to call these people
as terrorist but if you agree with the
view of the common Indians that the
britishers came to India to do business
they have no right to rule over us then
you would call these people as Freedom
Fighters you call these people as
Patriots same people same activity but
two different labels so before you give
a label you have to first try and find
out for what reason is the person
striving if you see the history of
American Revolution in the 18th century
in 177
the Americans got the freedom the
britishers were ruling them and the two
people who were called number one
terrorist was Benjamin Franklin George
Washington according to this British
government George Washington was
terrorist number one and later on this
same terrorist number one become the
president of
America imagine terrorist number one
according to British government becomes
the president of America and he happens
to be the Godfather of all the American
Presidents to follow including George
Bush so what we see today is whoever is
in power what he says carries
weight we can give example of the
aparted government of South Africa white
aparted government they imprisoned
Nelson Mandela for 25 years they called
him terrorist number one after the
aparted government was removed in the
new South Africa Nelson Mandela became
the president a few years later he get
The Nobel Prize for Peace imagine the
person who was called terrorist number
one is given the Nobel Prize for Peace
for the same activity not that first he
was bad and then he became good for the
same activity for which he was called a
terrorist later on he gets the Nobel
Prize for
Peace what we come to know whoever is in
power what he says turns out to be the
gospel truth which is not the
case so what we have to know we have to
go to the root cause so we as Muslims
what we have to do sister is we have to
speak for the h so if Allah has given
you the power with your hand you can
stop it do it with your mouth do the
mouth least you can do is curse in your
heart and pray for the um hope to answer
the
[Applause]
question my name is z Khan and I work as
a lab scientist my question is uh what
advice can you give uh to do practical
uh da such as in town center where you
can build a communic with
non-muslims ask a question that how can
you do practical dawa in dawa stalls Etc
brother the example that I gave in my
talk you can use that that try and use
the strategy of come to Common terms and
one thing is having the technique one
thing is knowing how to dawa for example
how to dawa with a co- passenger who are
traveling in a train with a different
technique how to dawa dawa star is a
different technique how to dawa in a
school is a different technique for this
we have a dawa training session where we
train people how to do dawa you can go
to our website irf Donnet on the dtp
dawa training program and the
information is there hope that answer
the
question I have a question here from a
non-muslim his name is ravinder he says
my name is ravinder I'm a non-muslim I
am a sik and I believe that all
religions are right and there is one God
everyone will go to heaven irrespective
of being a Muslim a sik etc there are
different disciplines to reach him I
presume God Sikhism Islam Etc what do
you have to say the brother POS the
question he's a sick he says all
religions are right all believe in one
God so what do you have to say we'll all
go to
heaven brother I am a student of
compared religion according to me all
religions are not right in the religion
itself there are many
contradictions in the religious
scriptures itself now coming to
Christianity if you analyze in
Christianity there are so many
contradictions in the Bible there are so
many things which are unscientific in
the Bible so Bible according to me is a
mixture it may contain the word of God
it contains the word of prophet it
contains the word of historians it even
contains pornography I'm sorry to say
how can I say that this pornography is
the word of God there are many
mathematical contradiction I can give a
talk only in the mistakes in the Bible
there are so many unscientific things
mention in the Bible the Bible says the
World is Flat I can give a talk on that
time doesn't permit me same thing with
The Vedas though I give talks on the
Veda there are many things which are
disagree in the Veda there are things in
the Veda which say that almighty God
created the Brahman from the head the
chhatria warrior class from the chest
the business class the vas from the
thighs and the sudras the low class from
the feet Islam doesn't believe that
human being have been created in cast
and levels so how can you say all
religions are right again you go to the
Hindu scripture it says that if a
husband dies then in the P the wife
should jump the Widow which is totally
wrong the Veda says that the sun moves
around the earth which is unscientific
in this by doing comparative religion I
cannot say that all religions are right
part of all the religions are right you
can say that which I wouldn't mind what
I'm saying only follow that part which
is right what is wrong you don't have to
follow so in this way brother I disagree
with you I'm a student of compared
religion you can see my cassettes I
spoken on various religions on Judaism
Christian ity Hinduism sism Buddhism Etc
so only what is right you have to follow
what is wrong you don't have to follow
hope that answer the
question uh question please from this
side we have to uh end our program very
shortly so I will ask to speed up inshah
asalam Alum my name is Sabina forgive me
for my unclarity this is a rather
spontaneous question um I have a friend
she's an atheist and on our endest
debates on the exist of God and all that
we talk about she has two claims she
makes two claims when I pose her with
the question of what the Quan says in
terms of the existence of the universe
and the world and how it states many
facts she turns around and she says well
that knowledge was not just for the
Quran it actually existed before the
Quran there is um scriptures there is
books before the Quran was even written
detailing information about the universe
so it's not just this knowledge that is
superior to the Quran what do I say back
to that is she lying do scriptures exist
I mean I have ignorance myself but you
know is this knowledge like was this
available before the Quran was written
and sorry secondly another claim she
makes is that I give the analogy of you
know you have something in creation who
knows it you know the Creator will know
about everything about it and I talk
about you know if there is no God how
can we possibly exist if you keep on
going further and further and further
and back there's no end and if no end
how do we exist then she says well from
a religious point of view you say well
God is the end well I say he's an
atheist who says God is the end who
created God that's my question thank you
this PO two questions which are again
commment the first question is that all
the things mentioned in the Quran were
already present before so what's new
it's present in other scriptures and
other books Etc that the first question
second question is who created God as
far as the first question is concerned I
do agree that c certain things were
present in time before the Quran but
they were not called as established
facts they were not called established
facts for example the thing I quoted
that the sun previously people thought
that the sun rotating there are certain
things which were there in the Greek
history and the philosophical history
but for example when the Quran speaks
about the spherical shape of the earth
these Greeks they believe that the Earth
was spherical
but no one believed in
them so certain facts not all a small
percentage what the science has come to
know today and what Quran mentions were
told by people previously but they
failed to realize that the same Greeks
mentioned 100 other things which were
unsan defic the same Greek even
mentioned that the Earth was center of
the universe which is totally wrong so
imagine if 100 points are mentioned and
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
picks up one which is correct that's
also not possible so I do agree age with
you sister that certain things were
mentioned before signs established as a
fact today but these things weren't
established that time and to say that
out of the 100 false things they mention
if one thing is right to pick up the one
correct thing is again also not possible
once it's possible but not thousands of
times s because only a person who is
even a scientist cannot do that only the
Creator himself can do and that's Allah
subhana tala so I do agree with you but
that portion which has been mentioned
earlier in earlier scriptures and other
philosophical books is a small portion
but that too along with that portion
there are other things which un
scientific mixed with that coming to the
second part of the question that who
created God normally people in dawa they
used a false strategy of logic which
tips itself most of the people when they
try to prove the existence of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala they say that
everything has a creator for example who
created this book how did the book come
into existence somebody created it who
created it and they go back where did
you come into existence who created you
your father who created your father the
grandfather and then goes to God who
created this microphone created the
factory who created The Factory and then
they try and prove who created the Sun
God who created the moon So based on
this they try and prove that everything
as a Creator which according to me is a
wrong
logic in my strategy what I spoke today
and never said everything as a
creator that is the atheist who told me
that the first person who will tell
about the mechanism of this thing is the
creator I never said that I say every
created thing as a
Creator but by definition almighty God
is
uncreated it is like there's a person
suppose my friend he comes and tells me
that my brother John was admitted in the
hospital he gave birth to a baby was it
a girl or a
boy can you guess sister
was it a girl or a
boy brother John gave birth to a baby
boy brother John was admitted to the
hospital he gave birth to a baby was it
a girl or a
boy can you
guess you can't guess can anyone
guess how can a man have a baby so to
ask the question he gave birth to a baby
whether it a girl or a boy is it logical
so same thing the definition of Allah is
uncreated the moment you say who created
Allah he sees it to be Allah therefore
the definition of God is uncreated
therefore almighty God has got no
Creator if he's a true almighty God hope
that anwers the
question uh due to the shortage of time
I will allow three very quick questions
and quick answers inshallah so three
questions 1 2 three and we'll have three
quick answers inshallah brother please
state your name and your profession Alam
alikum my name is gohar I'm an
accountant uh just very quickly it's a
pleasure to hear Dr Zak soon as the
first time I heard him it was one of my
ambitions to come and see you mashallah
you gave a lovely talk my question is
there's a famous Hadith saying by the
prophet peace be upon him that we should
seek knowledge unto China now I've
talked to a lot of brothers about this
and my perspective on it even though I
haven't researched it is that this
knowledge does not talk about religious
knowledge because the religious
knowledge at the time was in Saudi
Arabia where the Prophet peace be upon
him was and people all over the world
were coming to see him at that time for
religious knowledge but what is the
question brother what is the question so
my question is this Hadith does it
relate to religious knowledge or
knowledge of the Dunya science maths Etc
but as a question that the prophet said
that seek knowledge even if you have to
go to China because religious knowledge
was in Saudi Arabia it was worldly
knowledge so does it mean you can go to
China for worldly knowledge Point number
one brother according to
Alani this Hadith is a
MTH it's a fake Hadith it's not a
correct
Hadith because the center of Education
even at that time that time was in China
this Hadith is a fake Hadith but that
doesn't mean your question is not valid
you have to use other Hadith to prove
your question the first guidance given
by Allah subhana wa ta'ala to the whole
of humanity was not to pray was not to
give zakat it was in Surah alak chapter
96 verse number one and our beloved
Prophet Muhammad sallallah Al wasallam
said it's mentioned byi it is obligated
on every Muslim man or woman to acquire
knowledge so acquiring knowledge is f in
Islam it's compulsory it includes the
more obligatory is the dean knowledge
but that does not mean you cannot go and
travel even for worldly knowledge you
can as long as you fulfill the criteria
even for worldly knowledge you can as
long as it benefits you it gets you
closer to Allah subhana wa tala hope
that answerers the question
one more question on the sister side
please very quickly asalam Alum my name
is Zena um and I'm a graduate you may
have answered this question in part
already on the question of dawa many
people ask me how is it just for a very
good righteous non-muslim to go to hell
for example Mother Teresa um what
happens to their good deeds and what is
the best way to answer them thank you
sister has a question what about the
righteous non-muslim like Mother Teresa
will she go to heaven or hell
as I mentioned my talk the criteria to
go to heaven the criteria J are four
according
to by the token of time man is very
state of loss except those who have
faith those who have righteous deed
those who do dawa and those who exalt
people to Patient perseverance minimum
four criteria are required to go to jna
similarly when I was in school I passed
my icsc in 1982 there were minimum six
compulsory subjects English was there
mathematics science history geography
Hindi compulsory I ask you the question
sister in
science in five subjects out of six I
get 99 out of 100 in one subject I get
10 out of 100 in science will I pass
standard
10 yes or no no but I got 99 in English
99 in Hindi 99% in history if I fail in
anyone subject I fail similarly to go to
jna four criteria required Iman
righteous deed exalting people to
through dawa and exalting people to
Patient perseverance now you say Mother
Teresa was
righteous righteousness includes
offering Salah giving zakat many things
but even if I agree with you for sake of
argument or with a non-muslim that
Mother Teresa was righteous for sake of
argument in Islam righteous includes
many things which I feel mother T didn't
have but even if I agree with you for
sake of argument she gets
99 Only in one what about
Iman so if she does shik which is even
mentioned in the bible if you read the
Bible in the book of Deuteronomy chapter
number 5: 7-9 and the Book of Exodus
chapter number 20 verse number 3-5 it
says that thou shalt have no other image
of me Thou shalt not make unto thee any
Graven image of anything that is in
heaven above in the earth beneath and
the water beneath the Earth thou shallal
not bow down to them nor serve them for
I thy God thy Lord is the jealous God so
doing shik is even Haram in Christianity
and in the Quran Allah says in Surah MAA
chapter number 5 verse number 72 let's
see what is the verdict given by Jesus
Christ peace be upon Him Jesus Christ
peace be upon Him says in the Quran in
Sur ma 5: 72 Allah says
that who
they are doing KU they are blaspheming
those who say that Jesus Son of Mary is
Allah
subhana but said Jesus Christ peace be
upon
Him children of
Israel worship
Allah who's my Lord and your
lord anyone who associate partners with
Allah Allah will make Haram for
him and fire shall be his Dwelling Place
and he shall have no helpers in the
Hereafter so Jesus Christ peace be upon
him
said anyone who associate partners with
Allah Allah will make for him Paradise
will be forbidden for
him and shall be his dwelling place and
he shall have no help us in Hereafter so
according to Jesus Christ peace be upon
Accord to the Quran the Bible if any
human being does sh whether it be mother
t or anyone else they shall not enter
Jenna I have to apologize this will be
the last question we have a number of
handwritten questions here because of
the time constraints I will apologize
we'll be unable to cover these questions
in part of our program so uh my
apologies please brother can you state
the last question may I ask the other uh
brothers and sisters to take their seats
for the close of the program inshallah
asalam alikum my name is Adel Ahmed I'm
a 16-year-old student doing my gcses um
and my question regards uh Dr Nike's
statement previously about saying Merry
Christmas to non-muslim um makes us
somehow submit the fact that well the
idea that uh Christ was the son of God
and it makes us one of them now that
sort of shocked me in a sense that um
surely Allah uh in his almightiness
would know that my intention to saying
to someone Merry Christmas is as you
said just to improve relations now the
thing is that most people at least of my
generation the people who I come in
contact with don't actually celebrate
Christmas uh because they uh celebrate
Christ's birth but actually is a
commercial thing to get the latest PS2
or whatever it is um so could you just
please expand on that because I'm sort
of confused how saying Merry Christmas
could uh somehow um bring blasphemy the
brothers asked a question that he wants
to wish Merry Christmas to his friend so
that he can build relationships so
tomorrow you'll ask me the question why
can't I have a peg of alcohol to build
relationship why not
why what's wrong why can't I eat some
Pok with them why can't I go to church
and worship Jesus Christ peace be upon
him see you don't have to do anything
Haram for doing dawa for reaching the
goals you cannot use wrong means brother
what is Haram for them is Haram for you
also when you're wishing Merry Christmas
to them you're agreeing that Jesus
Christ peace be upon him was born on the
25th of December and you're agreeing
that he is the begotten Son of God which
is shik why it is wrong because the
Christians they believe that Jesus
Christ peace be upon Him is the begotten
Son of God now irrespective whether he
may be a practicing Christian or not
they celebrate because the birthday why
don't they celebrate any other day so if
you tell your Christian friend okay
forget if you don't believe in that
let's celebrate instead of 25th of
December let's celebrate on the 10th of
October will they agree they'll say no
but that does not mean don't do dawa I
do dawa on
Christmas I asked them that this is the
Christmas season why is it Christmas
they tell me oh oh it's Christmas
because Jesus Christ peace be upon him
was born on 25th of December who is this
Jesus peace be upon him oh Jesus is a
begotten Son of God then I tell him that
can you prove to me from one unequivocal
statement from the complete Bible where
Jesus Christ peace be himself say that
he's God he say worship me I do dawa why
do you have to use wrong means for doing
dawa you ask the question is saying
Merry Christmas wrong mean I'm telling
you it is wrong okay 100% wrong
according to me if you don't know what
Christmas is celebrated for like by
mistake if you don't know it is alcohol
and you you think it is Pepsi and you
have it Allah May forgive you so if you
don't know what is Christmas standing
for being in UK do you know what
Christmas stands for well as of now why
have you come from somewhere outside
well as of now I think it it stands for
a commercial I think it stands for a
commercial business that's what it
stands for it stands for a commercial
business a a place where people give
each other presents commcial the excuse
now don't don't on the bush I'm asking
the question do you know what is the
excuse for commercial business what is
the excuse why do they celebrate
Christmas for what because it's the
birth of Christ T finish you know about
it and do they consider Jesus Christ
peace be upon him as the Son of God
bigot son do you know that yeah I know
that but if you know that and then if
you wish Merry Christmas it is Haram if
you didn't know if you're coming from
timbak
to if you're coming from timbar to when
you did not know and in ignorance if you
wish Allah May forgive you if you don't
know that that is alcohol and if you
think it is Pepsi and you drink it Allah
May forgive you but if you know it and
you think you're building relationship
you know what you're doing you're
building a place in the
Janam so therefore brother for reaching
any good means you never have to adopt
wrong means you have to go as the
guidance of the Quran and the Sunnah
hope that answer the question
ald Brothers I'm so sorry we have no
more time I'm sorry brother we have no
more time uh my sincere apologies we
cannot ask any more questions we'll just
close with Reflections by Brother Shai
akal chairman of Harrow Central mosque
inshallah my job was to provide some
Reflections on the talk by Dr zaka Nike
but how do you provide Reflections in a
few words on such an amazing and such a
talk full of such information
I think the best that I can do is to
quote the Hadith of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallah alaihi wasallam in which he
said the best of mankind is he who
brings most benefit to them and to
summarize Dr Zak's talk the best benefit
that we can bring mankind is to bring
them Islam through dawa as Dr Zakir has
so eloquently taught
us on behalf of the committee of the
haris andos and the people of Harrow I'd
like to give my personal thanks and our
Collective thanks to Dr zaka Nike to Sir
ibal sakrani brother bash satar and his
colleagues